Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for a very special edition of the Monday morning podcasts and the
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday podcast,
whatever the hell you want to call it.
I have a very special guest here.
This is a guy I've been a fan of since,
I dunno,
like the first time I saw him.
82 or 83 please welcome drumming.
Legend Mr Kenny Aronoff.
Yeah man.
What's going on dude?
It's so cool.
See you.
Cause the first time I saw he was a buddy of mine in Chicago said you gotta see
this guy and went,
can I swear on this show?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh she goes yes.
Said,
oh my God,
this is fucking fun.
Massachusetts or something.
Yeah.
I didn't know.
I always thought you were in New York.
I didn't know you were Milwaukee.
So my mom grew up in the Bronx because I lived,
grew up in exit to which you,
we were talking about,
uh,
in Stockbridge.
I for some reason I adapted that New York thing.
Yeah.
It was not that pocket card and apple,
it was like motherfucker,
you know like the,
but that's a weird part of Massachusetts he's talking to exit to on the mass
pike where I was telling you I have one of the worst gigs and Lee Massachusetts
starting out but you know leaving there people throw in that time they will
just,
they will,
they will board is what I thought and they just want to look and for someone to
beat the shit out of.
And I looked like Ron Howard so that was going to be an easy night for them.
You show them that you know I did.
I didn't,
I just remember standing up there and so bad wanted to say something.
I know all they wanted me to do was just say that one thing and they were like,
cause they had this look on their face like come on,
come on,
freckles say it.
And I was just like I am going to get like curb stomped.
So I didn't say shit and I got paid and they were like following me around like
this group and they like,
they threw this dinner roll at me,
they missed and a,
it was weird.
It was like this weird,
I've told this story before.
It was like,
it was like this function room and next door to it was another function when was
part of this restaurant.
And then the other room was like a bachelor party and there was no closed door
and they just saw me standing there bombing in this restaurant and I just became
this entertainment thing.
And uh,
we sit down currently.
Is there a downtown?
Yeah.
I don't even remember the one stop.
No,
it was,
I remember it was like,
I remember pulling out of there and it was just like this,
it might be that that bar that they went to in Porky's remember that there was
just in the middle of the fucking woods.
It's like that.
I'm sure it's all developed now.
But I remember when I finally pulled out my little piece of Shit Ranger,
I had my head out the window like ace Ventura going,
fuck yeah,
you fucking kidding.
They were just laughing.
Um,
yeah,
I probably took five years off my life that night.
So anyways,
but that's a weird point in Massachusetts where there's like,
there's patriots fans and giants fans.
You start to get into that because it's 20 minutes from the border,
from the border.
Yeah.
So there's Yankee fans and red sox sense.
It's kind of like Connecticut,
like you know,
sort of halfway through you start getting out that way.
Like who do you root for?
So I guess,
I dunno,
but you're paying parents,
you said your mom was from the Bronx
juice from the box.
And my dad was from Patterson,
New Jersey and then they all kind of lived in New York for awhile and then they,
uh,
my dad got he studying paper and chemistry.
So in the lead there was a mill there,
there all these little meals up there in new England on the river.
And he worked for a division of Kimberly Clark in the drinking water out there
after that Gig.
I'm kidding.
We used to say,
man,
if you're in a boat and you fall into that river,
it's acid.
It'll burn you alive and you know,
stunk.
In the summer.
It was so bad.
They just dump chemicals in there to squash it up.
They don't do shit like that anymore.
I know.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
It's all good water.
That's why we got the uh,
water,
the earth and the air.
I know.
That's what's so fucked up about all this shit that people always talking about
on social media.
Like it's this big goddamn deal.
Like fat shaming and all of this shit.
It's like,
dude,
if those are prompt,
those problems are so down the fucking black.
As far as like what is going on right now.
Yeah.
Well water,
all of that.
Yeah.
All this shit.
You know,
some place in Africa in one month they're going to run out of water,
period.
I can't,
I can't listen to him because it just cause there's no fucking solution.
No one pays attention and then if you try to address it,
conservatives claim liberals and levels bring conservatives and then they just
keep plowing ahead and I have fun.
I want to hear what I'm going to say.
What are you gonna say?
Well,
let's,
let's stop pretty strong about like,
you know,
people,
people are fucking students.
They're like little kindergarteners still.
I don't care how old you are.
I don't think the world is evolving at all.
Maybe with technology it's the same shit.
I cannot believe.
Like who gives a fuck about that?
And who gives a fuck about that?
Oh really?
You really that uptight about that?
Holy Shit.
Or like,
you know,
some big issues was there won't mention whether it's squabbling,
dude,
just make a little bit.
Just this is the thing,
you know,
you have to dance around because you had some big issues that I'm not gonna
remember.
You're upset about this and I know every issue that you fucked.
You're talking about it,
but you can't bring it up because then you have like 80 soccer moms and this
thing 80 soccer moms will actually make the news because they're going to talk
about that.
Okay.
You are whatever fucking reason.
So you gotta,
you gotta kind of make the news that you've got to dance between the raindrops.
I'm to get my ass dude,
we gotta get some padding on this table and he's sort of shifting of weight.
That's right.
Yeah.
So anyway,
check.
So,
Oh man,
I'm going to get my ass kicked right now,
but I call it,
I grew up western mass,
super liberal,
super democratic,
you know,
uh,
just everybody's just,
when they vote democratic all the way down,
doesn't matter if it was Hitler,
if he's a Democrat,
Democrat side,
I'm just blown away.
I call him vicious liberals.
No,
that was been out here.
It's
crazy.
Like people are so,
like a real true liberal was my dad,
uh,
liberal.
My Dad,
you know,
we grew up Jewish,
but my dad would listen to Hitler talk just to see what he had to say to,
wouldn't yell at him.
He would talk and then he'd tell Hitler that he was fucked and so many words,
but he would at least taught me.
He like knew the guy or he's watching the tapes,
he's talking to the TV.
He's a true liberal.
I was just thinking like that was the ultimate like fucking odd couple movie
when they like roommates in college is some shit.
No,
actually my dad was bombing Hitler was,
he was in a bomb.
Was it just leveled Hitler?
But my point is my dad was a true liberal.
He would listen to anybody.
Didn't matter what it is,
but nowadays it's like a calm,
vicious slippers.
They're like,
they're more conservative and radical.
They totally,
a true liberal is somebody who listens and,
and will at least accept somebody else's opinion.
No matter how radical it is.
Liberal is,
you're open minded at the fact that you have that opinion.
You'll listen to it and everything.
Right,
but you this vicious.
This is like,
it's like,
no,
there's destroying careers.
They will just,
if you had like it's basically we're liberal think what we think but if you
don't we're going to go after your career and it's like,
it's no different than I remember what the happened to the Dixie chicks when
they just express your opinion about the current president and I remember like
Fox News was saying like,
well they have a right to state their opinion and we have a right to have,
you know,
state our opinion.
It's like you didn't state your opinion,
you state your opinion,
then you systematically tried to destroy their fucking ability to earn a living
that's not tit for tat.
No.
You know what I mean?
So that's what I'm saying,
that sandbox stuff.
I said,
well it's still a bunch of little kids still.
How'd we get on that?
I don't know what I wanted to talk because I know everybody always talks to you
about drumming and all that type of shit.
What?
Nobody doesn't talk to you about to you.
How,
I don't want to say how old you are,
but I'm old.
Okay.
Your all,
how do you stay in the fucking shape you're in your shredded?
Well,
you know,
and this is me kind of out of shape because uh,
uh,
so busy right now,
but um,
you know,
what happened was at a certain point in my life and it was early,
it was like when I was with Mellencamp and I might have been 27 coming out of a
pretty wild time party wise,
you know,
and suddenly went,
this ain't right.
I think clicked in my head.
Now I'm not saying I remember what party you are at and what you are looking at
to be like,
I'm a part of this.
I can't judge this five year period,
dude,
the party
kind of
something to 19 something that party,
you mean it was like I was open for business.
It was,
was it,
was it something that it was a feeling that was gradually working at you or just
just one night just boogie nights.
Shit happen.
You were just like,
all right,
I got to stop this.
Well,
first of all,
the environment I was in was just,
it was just who was just a bunch of kids in rock bands is partying and shit was
available,
you know,
and,
and you're drinking and you and I had abundance of energy.
So,
you know,
I,
I just,
if I drank too much,
I wake up next,
aw,
that sucks.
And then just go right.
But what happened was,
so they,
I just started,
I said my stomach started feeling like I couldn't,
when I was eating,
I was like,
it was a,
wasn't digesting food wheel good.
I was just beating myself up.
I wasn't taking care of myself.
And during that time I was,
I was always a jock.
I was a three letter men jock in high school Lacrosse,
a ski team and a soccer east coast shit,
you know.
And uh,
I ended up going to Umass for music and my freshman year I was on the Lacrosse
team.
That was the number one,
Lacrosse,
number nine,
the cost team in the countries that or Boston Amhurst.
And I went there as a party school.
I used to have like when I was growing up,
once a year,
somebody died at southwest that jump off the building or something?
No,
they would ride the elevators.
They would ride the elevators surfing and somebody every year would fall down
the fucking shaft.
Oh,
did you go?
Did you go there?
I went to Umass.
I went everywhere.
I went,
every dude I fucking,
I,
whenever I went to Umass Boston,
uh,
NC state Emerson and it was accepted at northeastern,
I think.
I can't remember.
I just,
I just sort of bounced around and,
uh,
I hated school.
I hated it.
I just wasn't in your thing.
I didn't,
yeah,
I just didn't give a F.
I just want to get the fuck out of it.
And I wanted to do,
have fun.
I wanted to play drums.
I wanted to joke around and wanted to drink.
No Kid.
Really.
Yeah.
That's what I wanted to do.
And there was a few subjects that I would,
I would like some history,
but I can't fucking,
yeah.
Old,
old,
old shit.
And I'm saying,
yeah,
I,
I had a purpose in college so it worked out.
But Oh,
you went,
like I was hardcore classical.
I know there was no school of rock.
Berkeley was still mostly a jazz school,
seeing my family,
everybody went to college.
So,
you know,
but at that time it's like you do.
So I'm a,
I'll be a music major and I was self taught drummer,
you know,
and there was this one kid in stock,
but it was getting better.
And uh,
it's like,
can,
what are you doing?
Well,
I'm taking lessons from this percussions from the Boston Symphony Orchestra.
Art depressed lived in,
uh,
you'll know,
not,
not yet.
No,
no,
no.
He lived in Newton,
Newton.
So,
um,
it's the first time.
So I went,
okay,
I'm going to take a lesson with this guy because I was real competitive,
you know,
just being a jock and all.
And I had long hair down my shoulders.
So it was a hippy jock,
you know,
so,
and I was always playing in the band.
I was always,
I was really popular in high school and I have identical twin brother,
so we both were in the bands.
Both on sports teams had long hair.
Yeah.
Heckle and Jeckle and we were like,
did you start in lethal weapon at any point?
That's how I'm thinking you guys with the long blonde hair.
So
I go down there,
I'll never forget when I go down to Newton on a bus,
Greyhound bus from Lee,
that's it from me.
But I was hung over because I had been hanging out with the varsity football
team,
varsity soccer team and the cheerleaders the night before drinking vodka on a
mountain.
You know what that is?
Fire drinking vodka that night and didn't get laid,
but you know,
I was hanging with those old,
you know,
two years in high school.
That's old chick.
Right.
You know what I mean?
That's like big time it bigger tits again,
get everything is more developed,
you know.
So anyway,
yeah,
I get to Newton,
I'm like,
whoa.
I bought,
was in the back,
probably puking in the bus and I get there and this is Arthur press,
his old school.
He goes,
what's your name?
He says,
Kenny Kenny what?
Uh,
Kenny Aronoff.
He says,
what have you prepared for me today?
Oh No.
You know what?
If you put what?
Um,
uh,
we'll do you play malates I'm like,
what's malice?
He said,
Marimba vibes.
I said,
no,
I'm getting smaller and smaller.
This is old school guy,
man.
This guy is hardcore.
Then he goes,
would you prepare a Timpani pieces?
I don't play Timpani.
What do you play?
This is what played drum set.
Well,
come on down here,
let's say,
see play.
Some concept puts on spinning wheels by blood,
sweat and tears.
And I actually been jamming to that and my barn,
I had a barn and western mass and that's where we had all our rock bands.
My parents lived every,
we always had the rock bands were rehearsing at my place.
It's got a barn.
And my parents loved it because they,
the kids were at home.
Even when we were smoking pot and drinking,
they just,
there we were,
you know,
so I sit down in 30 minutes,
he ripped me off the off the drum set and points to a rubber black pad.
Well,
how did you feel you were applying?
You?
Look,
I always spinning.
I'm going to nail this.
I was feeling it.
I thought I was good,
but he didn't think so.
So he puts it on the pad that basically he kicked my ass.
And that was a pivotal point in my life.
I'm like,
a lot of kids would have gone fuck this man.
I don't,
I don't need you.
I'm playing in a rock band.
I'm getting laid,
I'm having fun.
What do I need?
This fucking shit.
But something clicked and I have to say it's in my DNA that this is good for me.
And I,
my dad bought me a old set of vibes for $300 from Carol's music in New York.
And now I had that and I,
she was sports background,
um,
gave you that,
that you,
that made you not afraid of like,
oh,
new information.
This guy,
this guy's been hard on me because this guy seems like a coach to me.
He was totally cool.
Yeah,
you're walking in like the blue chip prospect a,
I've got this all down and then he just goes,
you don't know shit.
Yeah.
It wasn't,
no.
Did the cause back then.
You don't mean the coaches back then were like marine sergeants.
There was,
back then it was no handholding,
there's no cartilage,
there was no internet,
there was none of this.
She should,
they look at athletes now like they're all a bunch of date rapists and all this.
They with Frat boys and all that.
And they totally lose like the confidence that you get from playing sports,
the a,
the ability to work with a group,
the ability to get your fucking ass kicked and lose and shake it off like links
to a couple of water and when the next quarter,
because yeah,
you learn all this great stuff,
but now it's just Kinda,
you know,
it's sort of like the nerd time.
So like their perspective and they don't fucking play sports.
So their perspective of it is as is as fucked up,
be fair is the jocks perspective of them,
you know?
Well,
you know what,
while they're sitting there being entitled,
waiting for Shit to happen and,
and,
and pussyfooting around,
I'm going to go over them and take what they're waiting for and I'm sorry I am
not let it back down on it.
That's how,
that's how it works.
So I mean,
back then,
you know,
it's like my parents were really sensitive and cool but bad dude get you ass up.
There was no,
no,
no handholding or titled.
I'm grateful that
I decided with the teacher,
the teacher said,
your kids acting like an asshole.
They would look at you and bill,
what's your problem?
Like an asshole instead of
take out their cell phone,
video and then the teacher has to apologize because you're not raising your kid,
right?
I,
you're dumping this douche offered school and they have to deal with your bad
parenting for six hours,
eight hours a fucking week.
I mean teachers are grossly,
grossly underpaid.
Oh too closely.
And to pay those,
why would you want to be a teacher?
It's like you've got not only you got everybody against you or not.
Now with all these little fucking kids there and,
and you,
you do anything it seems they take out a camera and then they're automatically,
right.
Dude,
it's brutal man.
I Dunno,
I'll tell you,
we do sound like a bunch of old guys going,
oh my God,
he's catch today.
But there is an element of like,
Geez,
you know what?
Fuck him.
You know what I missed.
I'm writing it off.
Shake it off.
Okay,
so check this out.
I really do
believe that people should embrace the fear,
the anger,
embarrassment,
failure,
all that negative stuff.
I believe you should squeeze it,
hug it,
throw it away and get your fucking ass in gear and move forward.
What is some of your top like five or whatever,
three,
four,
five most embarrassing moments that you had on your way up to become an hotel?
The worst was so I,
I this,
I know we keep getting all I find she studied classical music.
I got to go to school choice.
I get into umass barely again into umass,
barely.
But the guy he put up like some Marimba music,
I'd never played Marimba.
I'd played five,
puts it up on the site and meeting it and I suck.
I miss every note.
He takes it away.
Wait,
no,
give it back.
It's a Marimba.
That's not the Lionel Hampton thing is that's the vibe
members wouldn't,
it's long and you learn classical like violin music on it so that you can learn,
you know about harmony and scales and you become not just a drummer,
but you come a well rounded musician.
So I didn't realize this,
but when I go read,
wrote my books next to him,
jog log,
it does.
I really am a fighter fight guy,
not a fight or flight guy.
That's DNA,
you know.
So anyway,
he,
I demanded that music back and I just wouldn't give up and that's,
he went along and I love teaching this guy.
This guy wants to work.
So bottom line is,
who's this chick there?
You bombed on that thing and he was just like,
this isn't right for you.
And you,
you know,
he,
I,
you know,
part of your,
when you auditioned for school in classical music,
you have to perform on snare drum.
You have a piece,
you prepare it and then he's going to want to ask you rudiments technique and
then sight read music.
Same with mallets.
You prepare a pieces.
You say,
well,
give me a c major scale.
Give me a d minor scale,
give me a play an Arpeggio,
give me an augmented chord.
And then,
uh,
and they give you a sheet what they're going to test you on.
But then they put that music up that,
you know,
you've never seen.
You got to play in rhythm and,
and hit all the notes.
And I always sucked at that.
And
by the time I graduated Indiana University,
I want a concerto competition where I was,
um,
I can play it.
I got it.
It's,
it's a violin concerto that I saw Itzhak Perlman play as his encore virtuosic
beautiful piece.
And I knew in my senior year I was going to have to play a virtuosic violin
concerto or a violin piece on Marimba to pass Indiana.
I went from Umass to four years of Indiana,
which was the number one school.
That school,
my teacher was like a navy seal commander.
It's like he would try to wash you out because the school was number one.
It had to keep that status,
so anybody who's not capable,
they would wash you out.
He would just,
I'm going to get the embarrassing moment,
this guide walk in and he'd be like,
look,
taking notes on the last student,
and he'd be,
he'd hit the desk,
which meant give me your lesson book.
He'd open it up if he's still taking notes.
She looked at it and go,
Oh,
F sharp harmonic minor two octaves,
don't you?
Right.
Hands three,
four and I'm still standing there with my book bag.
He looks at me goes,
are you happy here at Indiana University?
Kenny,
do you want to stay here?
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Jesus.
When you walk in,
you get your ass in front of the instrument and be ready to play.
You never know when a conductor is going to walk and say three,
four,
let's go.
You have to be ready.
He was training you to be a marine.
And this stuff carried,
carried forward into my entire life.
So anyway,
I met,
I met at,
at,
at Umass,
and this is hot jr just chicks talking about,
tell us it's as hot as you can be in classical music.
It's not like rock and roll.
But then when she was the hottest shoes,
classical hot,
classical,
hot,
I hear a powdered wig.
Nice tents in a potter wick.
It's funny I hear that she's going to go to this place called Aspen School of
music.
It's one by Julliard.
So all I'm thinking is chick,
you know,
and I'm like,
oh I'm going to go,
I've got a coat.
I don't realize it's one by Julio,
which is the number two school in the country and it's,
I'm not going to get in.
So,
but the sheet they tell you,
you got to prepare in the audition from four to three out of the four different
areas,
snare drum,
Timpani,
Malik's and multiple percussion.
So I audition on a four cause I'm not that great yet.
So the pieces are,
you know,
kind of like beginner,
intermediate.
I send the tape and I don't hear it from them.
Last Day of school,
I got my dad's station wagon.
I'm going to leave a umass.
So my summer was a study with Arthur press had this cool band,
Allman brothers band.
And I had this girlfriend
that didn't know about the cellist.
But anyway,
I,
uh,
I'm,
I'm leaving Amhurst and I went,
Oh shit,
I forgot to check my mail and go back.
And they told the male I had some mail and it looks like you've got to check and
went,
oh shit,
what's this open up excepted to aspen two weeks before.
So it must have been,
somebody must've canceled because you don't tell somebody two weeks before.
So two weeks later I go to aspen.
By the way,
the trick didn't show up.
She didn't go,
oh,
the classical,
she did not go.
So I'm there,
dude.
I was,
they went to the doers.
Worst percussionists there.
All these kids with Julliard prep had been playing Timpani Marimba when they
were in diapers.
You know,
I'm doing scales,
Doo,
Doo Doo.
And they're going playing these Bach partitas.
And virtuosic shit.
And I have a picture of me with all those people.
And the funny thing is it's kind of like your story.
Worst guy there.
I became the most,
I mean as far as famous visual guy,
out of all of them a lot.
Some went became lawyers,
some became,
this came that one guy did get a Timpani job in San Francisco Orchestra,
which is big,
but nobody became visible and a rock star like me.
I'm not saying I'm better,
I'm just saying it's just ironic.
I thought,
okay.
I thought when I was there as a piece of shit cause okay,
one day I'm in rehearsal,
orchestra rehearsal.
We're playing a Tchaikovsky symphony or something or Romeo and Juliet and the
orchestra is going [inaudible] and then they stop and assembles gold.
It's a whole for me.
Well I'm counting,
I didn't know what I should have done is studied the music and just pretty much
memorize eight measures before you come in.
She's going to have to count.
You don't have to worry about counting the Firelands do [inaudible] not me.
I'm going 100 100 to 103 104 why don't wait,
what is it?
Wait,
100 101 two,
341013102 I'm up to 300 and what's that one oh one oh,
was that what?
Oh,
to come.
Fuck.
I'd come in in the wrong place.
This motherfucker,
he didn't just go,
excuse me.
He wasn't playing cymbals,
the hallmarks or turns around.
I'm peeing in my pants,
so me embarrassed and he says,
guilt.
You know when to come in,
count from me.
Uh,
okay.
So I stopped counting.
I kind of like 200 measures.
He's just trying to ridicule me.
Who's an asshole and I get to the point where I'm supposed to come in and I
don't play.
What did you play?
I said,
you said count his say place Jesus to sunrise.
Me.
That fucking was that movie with a
guy was playing the drum slash yeah,
the guy kept yelling.
I couldn't,
I couldn't watch the movie.
Yeah.
I was just like,
just join a different band.
Why would you sit here and let somebody,
if I've had a kid,
let somebody talk to them to that level.
It's like one thing of just trying to make you better,
but like when it gets to the point,
somebody was like taking their life out on you,
you know?
Or at least push back.
You know,
why don't you,
why don't you go fuck yourself.
Get one of those.
Yeah.
I know it was Spencer more instead of sitting there.
I don't know.
That kind of goes against what we've been talking about earlier where we were
saying like,
you know,
you've got to take his little bit.
It's both.
There's this bullet.
Yeah,
it's a skill.
It's always a skill.
What weighs heavier?
Me Punching him in the face or verbally telling them and get my ass kicked and
fired.
Is that more important than hanging in here and just getting better?
You make a decisions.
Always a scale to me.
You know,
it's like the coach that's up your ass or the teacher in many cases or some of
the people I've worked for and you go,
you know,
I remember people telling me,
I won't mention names,
just say I can't believe you put up with that shit.
And I'm like,
well number one hit single on the radio right now.
I know.
I mean it's like
you didn't go on the road with them.
It was just a studio gig.
No,
it was full blown.
Oh,
on the road.
Yeah.
You know,
I've been so fucking lucky in this business and I also think it's because when I
finally started doing shit in this business where like it used to be back in the
day,
there was like 20 giant slices of Pie.
And so there was always sort of like 20 people at any moment who just could snap
their fingers in.
The whole world had to move.
And now it just seems like each one of those 20 slices has been chopped up a
million times.
So it's like you,
you can't be an asshole anymore.
You know what I mean?
Did you call it sorta like,
can't be that,
uh,
you know,
tipping over the craft service table and I refuse to come out of my trailer and
said,
are you telling me that my career is over since we've been caulking
let me band?
No,
I've,
I've definitely like,
I've never on,
on any,
like on any acting Gig,
everybody I've ever worked with,
they always showed up on time and you hear all these stories.
I've never had,
I've only been a course doing that stuff for like the last few years,
but I've,
I've never run into that.
But then you always heard these stories,
you know,
I first got into this business about,
people would get like a sitcom and then all of a sudden the creators of the show
are banned from the set and uh,
they refused to do the lines.
They're tank and table reads because they're mad at the writers,
all of that Shit.
I never saw any of that.
That's because now there's somebody sitting eight,
there's a hundred people behind you.
What did it take you gig for a third of the pay in rock and roll?
Well,
I hear you want to go on tour,
I won't mention names.
Some chick's doing stadiums and they're paying the musicians that I'm like,
are you kidding me?
I said,
that's,
I used to make that in a day recording.
They used to and the thing is is that there's kids who go out and do it for half
as much in a room asleep
on the floor just to do it.
I said unbelievable run of mine.
Tell me about that.
Doing like some giant like stay like where the Falcons a plant.
Yeah.
And he was just going through it.
If you knew the money that he will make an,
it's just like the,
the artists gets all of it.
Yeah.
And then you know,
yeah,
we're going back,
I'm sleeping in the bathtub,
this other guy sleeping in the bed and blah,
blah blah.
And it's just,
what happened was the accountants got control of the business accounts and the
business people and where the artists thought and they suck up to the artists.
You know,
artists are happy because you're saving money.
Saving.
Well,
I'm saying you this amount of money,
if you put these people there and you paid them this and you're this and you're
that and you know,
that'll give anybody a hard on you.
Especially if you were a struggling musician.
This is a point in the fork in the road where I think a struggling musician
either becomes the person that was kind of keeping them down
or they go,
that's not the way that treat people.
Right.
And they,
most of them don't.
They become just like that or worse.
I've worked with these guys where,
you know,
they kind of like,
they got screwed.
Yeah.
They got screwed by the label.
They got screwed like by managers.
It good.
Yeah,
but that doesn't mean you screw your band.
I saw a guy saw guy recently,
I was watching one of these is called side man.
Yeah.
That was something that I think or did something and that there's a guy in that
and he's the black blues guys.
No,
no,
no.
This is just talking about hired gun,
like a hired gun.
So this guy,
basically this guy was a in the on,
what's the story?
All right,
it was,
it was the nine inch nails.
Oh,
I know all those guys.
I know both sides.
So there was a guy I know and he,
he becomes the guy that was treating him a certain way.
He went and became,
that guy goes,
hey man,
cause you're going onto to a giant house.
The end of this tour,
I'm going back to live with my parents.
He goes a basement.
Yeah.
He goes,
you want to make some money,
right.
A record.
So he went out and he wrote a record and then he turned around and he did the
exact same thing to all those people.
I thought he would have eased off the gas a little bit.
You know what I mean?
He,
I like,
no,
fuck you man.
That's,
this is the game.
This is the game.
So I s I watched it.
I didn't know how to feel about it.
Like I was sitting there going like,
well I wouldn't do that shit.
But it's easy for me as a comedian because you know,
we don't have to split the money as far as with like other bands.
Yes.
You know,
it's just all the other shit taxes.
Yeah.
Well I mean,
but the,
you know,
not to defend him or that position is that,
that's the business makes could make you feel like,
you know,
I got just beat up so much that now it's my turn to be on top and fuck everybody
else.
That kind of thing.
It can do that.
But
there was that,
that was a time like that and stand up.
It was a certain comedy club and uh,
it was just a really bad time for it.
And it just had this really negative vibe.
And there was all of these guys that at the time had TV shows and movie careers
and they would come down to the club and they would do like an hour and a half,
two hours,
not worked out any material,
just leaning on the mic stand guy ass.
So what else is going and just showing off that they could burn the light and
meanwhile would bump like 20 comics.
And like people just start saying,
you know,
and then you couldn't say I'm going home because then the club would get mad at
you.
So you would literally go from having like an 11 o'clock spot to waiting around
to like two 30 in the morning.
There would be nobody there.
And this was every fucking night.
And you felt that energy in the back of the club of certain comics being like,
man,
I can't wait til I get a fucking Sitcom.
I'm going up there and I'm going to fucking burn the light.
I'm gonna make everybody else way.
And fortunately,
right around that time,
uh,
the Seinfeld show was ending and I would never forget it was down in the Improv
on Melrose.
And Jerry Seinfeld came in to do a set end.
He had to do 20 minutes and he did 20 minutes.
He came up with shit that worked.
And then in the middle he tried out some new stuff,
had a big closer,
and then he just went around,
hey,
any questions,
bing,
Bang,
boom,
and done and walked off that same club that you would know this was a the,
that sets a great example.
That's what I was sitting in it.
And I remember.
And then wanting them,
oh,
don't leave,
you know,
leave them wanting more,
all of that shit.
And I was just like,
he was Tro,
tro,
total fucking pro.
And I just remember thinking like,
that's how you do it.
That's how you do it.
And,
and the thing you were there and every comic like who watched left excited that
they got to see him work and do his thing and then you don't give a shit if you
get bumped 20 minutes to see Seinfeld.
Yeah.
But you know,
if he went up there and for fucking two hours,
yeah.
Torture.
There was a meandering,
you know,
had a little fucking piece of,
just going up there,
being famous just to be famous.
And the fact that he didn't do it,
I meant that always stuck with me.
I'm like,
all right,
that's,
that's how you felt.
You.
What you aspire to be.
That classy and that professionals.
That's the shit.
Okay.
Time for some reeds here.
All right,
Sun basket everyone.
All right.
My health seeking friends,
the days of not following through with resolutions
because the days of sun basket or just beginning,
which means you,
I mean,
which means you are going to keep your resolution this year.
You fat bastard because Sun Basket is making it makes it easier than ever and
today you can get $35 off your first order when you go to sun basket.com/burr B
u.
R.
R when when you have healthy meals regularly delivered to your door with sun
basket and you don't eat ice cream afterwards,
you're going to drop the weight.
It's easy to stay on track.
I'm talking about ingredients like organic produce responsibly raised me.
Hey,
it's past your bedtime.
Get back in the
sustainably source.
I,
my daughter's laughing.
I mean sustainably sourced fish,
organic pasture raised eggs,
organic non GMO Tofu.
Oh and the housemates sauces he can't find anywhere else.
And it's all personalized.
Sung basket lets you mix and match from lean and clean,
gluten free,
Vegan,
vegetarian,
Mediterranean,
Mediterranean and more.
Sorry,
I got my Invisalign and not to mention tons of variety with 18 recipes to choose
from.
Festival.
Each delicious easy recipe is ready in about 30 minutes.
I gave you more here.
There's more right there.
Um,
go to sun basket.com/birth today to learn more and get $35 off your first order.
That's sun basket.com/spur for $35 off sun basket.com/burp.
Okay,
movement watches.
Everybody.
You guys have heard me talk about movement.
You know who's you know those two college dropouts?
You didn't eat all of that.
It's right here.
It's right there.
There you go.
Um,
you know there's two college dropouts that started their own watch company.
This company has grown like crazy and now almost 2 million watches sold in 160
countries.
They continue to revolutionize the fashion world.
You have.
You didn't got it right here.
You got to write something like that,
um,
in the country is to revolutionize and fashion on belief.
That style shouldn't break the bank.
Buddy,
I don't know if you've checked the site out lately,
but they have doubled the number of watch styles and are still expanding
movement watches.
Start at just $95.
Good Lord
here,
move and figured out that by selling online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup at the best part for the best possible price.
Classic design,
quality construction styled minimalism.
Get 15% off today.
You like that part?
Then you know with free shipping and free returns,
go to movement,
watches.com/ [inaudible] see why the movement keeps growing.
Check out there expanding collection.
Go to mvmt.com/burr join.
Okay,
and lastly,
but certainly not leastly legal zoom man national small business month at legal
zoom is here.
Hi.
Whether you're just starting out are already have a business as a lot you can
take advantage of right now.
Just go to legalzoom.com/startup during March match to download your free
business startup kit.
You'll get a ton of great,
great information.
For example,
you can find out how to maximize your business to deductibles under the new tax
law.
Plus you'll get great discounts.
Your kid includes special deals from legal zone along with their service
partners.
So you can save a bunch of money financing,
marketing and operating your business.
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm,
but they know you need to.
You need to tap into the right resources to run a successful business.
That's why their business startup kit,
that's what their business started kid is all about.
Um,
go to legal zoom.com/startup to download your free business startup kit today.
There's no obligation,
just free business sources.
This offer is only available in match.
So if you're listening after,
then you can still enjoy special savings by using the code bur bur are when you
check out@legalzoom.com.
Well tell me what,
what are you doing to work out,
dude?
You like shredded?
Well,
I have a gym in my house and what I and w w I a.
Okay.
What did I do?
Okay,
so I lived with it.
Definitely.
I,
I live,
I have eight steps to help.
Right.
You got another book about this.
I read,
you mentioned sex,
drums and rock and roll.
Is his book the hardest hitting man in show business?
Kenny Aronoff
did.
We did that.
I left that out of the book.
That's why I'm writing a second book.
Um,
they,
they cut 300,
300 pages out of that book.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm doing a hundred million records sold dude.
So,
so I,
I'm just a workaholic,
you know,
and uh,
and so they said it's too long.
The,
the magic number is 300,
three 25 pages.
I went,
they left out this whole scene with me and Cameron Diaz me meeting Dave Grohl
when he comes up to me,
I'm hung over.
I just played with a buddy,
which big band in New York and me and Matt soil out all night just partying it
up.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm hung over checking out and Dave skinny Dame goal comes up to me and goes,
he can eat Dave,
which,
what did you do or is it,
ah,
uh,
oh.
Hi Dave.
Yeah,
I'm flying home a little hung over.
You got to stay in town.
I got to showcase that you're going to come.
He's a jumping around and go jack rabbit.
And uh,
he says,
uh,
I got a new band,
man.
It's just cruel man.
Is it,
what's the name of those?
It's foo fighters.
Mammon.
God,
it's a weird name
that didn't make the book.
Wow.
You just name drop and man,
they said you can't have,
I have to admit.
Yeah,
but nerds like me,
I want to hear those stories.
It's Cambodia as you would like to.
It was basically I turned,
you know,
I,
I didn't,
you know,
the sunset Marquis member,
the whiskey bar,
the whiskey bourbon whiskey bar in the sunset Marquis hotel hotels,
the bar in the sunset marquee,
you know that,
that said the hotel,
it's a kind of a boutique hotel.
All the WHO's go a few on Alta Loma,
uh,
go down the hill off of sunset in there.
Okay.
It was,
I mean,
every,
you walk in there and be Jeff back,
it'd be you two.
It'd be the stones.
It was and only could hold 75 people is really intimate.
All the rock bands would stay there.
So I'm standing there and I'm doing a record with the Tony Iommi and Billy
Corgan from the Pam,
uh,
Tony Iommi from Sabbath.
So doing a solo record and those,
that was a 13 hours session that one day,
uh,
with 45 minute break,
you do cheese,
this is,
this is to be real bad as such.
But,
and you know,
you know,
no,
no vocals listened to.
It was just,
we were writing the song right there,
three movements and bill,
it doesn't fuck around.
It's not a party time.
It's fucking all work.
So that night I'm sitting in there having a drink with Tony and a whole bunch of
shit happened at night.
I think it,
that might be in the book,
but I also know,
she told me Myers,
I just left the Mellencamp band two years prior and I've been in that band for
17 years.
So it was like a divorce.
All of a sudden I see the bass player come running out of the bar.
I'm in the,
in the lobby because it was,
it was two filled and he's like,
fuck this.
And he's pissed.
I'm like,
Toby,
what's going on man?
He says,
AH,
fuck it.
He gets the elevator takes off.
I'm like,
wow,
what's going on?
I walk in there and there's the Mellencamp band.
So it was kind of a,
an emotional
tug,
a divorce and seeing your ex wife suddenly and the new drummer,
you know,
and he's,
it's awkward,
you know,
but then I look over out in the courtyard and there was the tour manager for,
uh,
the Pumpkin's about six,
eight and he brings me over the bottom line.
Is he smiling?
He just wanted to see what it'd be like.
I saw Cameron Diaz says she just doesn't that big first movie.
Something about Mary and some guys talking to her.
And the bottom line is,
it was Jimmy Chamberlain Dorma from the Pumpkin's.
He wanted to see us connect,
you know,
me,
what would happen.
Anyway,
he,
he said some drinks and stuff and he's just talking to her and I,
I was just so uptight from everything going on that day.
And then the Mellencamp band and like,
ah,
you know,
bottom line is Jimmy and I,
he tapped and Jimmy,
Jimmy and I just can't top what it was,
didn't work out the way I wanted to.
So I stood there and I'm like,
that's not how I wanted meet Jimmy Chamberlain.
I cool down when I tapped him on the shoulder and said,
Jimmy,
listen.
Ah Man,
I uh,
I respect you so much.
You are one of my favorite dramas.
Banis I feel so honored to be playing in your band too.
It's just,
God damn,
I didn't,
I'm sorry.
I've met you like this and I would love to just tell you how much I appreciate
you.
And then I walked off,
it's about two in the morning.
The bar closes up comes comedy is lands in my lap,
put your arms around me,
lands in my lap.
Now I'm 1998 so I was like,
just a ball testosterone.
And my normal game of play was like,
if a chick lands on your lab at two in the morning,
what do you think you could say or do?
Right.
So,
but this is Cameron Diaz,
gorgeous hot.
And she whispers,
you know,
with that smile on those lips and she whispers in my ear,
it's somebody would have probably thought she was kissing me.
Listen was Maya says,
you know,
I heard what you said to Jimmy.
That was really,
really cool.
And I look at our smile and that's usually when I go,
hey,
I got a room upstairs.
I can get some liquor,
but you want to eat,
you want some?
Uh,
what,
what are you want?
You know,
and I'd put my move.
I didn't put that in a book.
They said,
well,
you didn't have sex with him.
Like the part,
the reason why I should have put that in my book is this,
the freeze when I didn't say anything to her,
which was not normal for me was I have fucking session the next day,
13 hours would Billy Corgan and Tony Iommi though.
And the point of this book is work came over everything.
Well,
she had
turned down the potential of that.
Uh,
yeah,
you're definitely a workaholic who just wanted to send this.
I'm hoping Cambodia is like come finds me someday while I'm giving him one of my
speeches on stage and says I'm here to collect.
Yeah,
we'll probably be wheelchairs and Bab colostomy bags and I'll be,
yeah,
not so much now.
Hey you a name,
you were talking about working out.
Yeah.
What about Diet and all that?
I'd still in the book that came up was with the eight things.
First thing.
Number one,
lifting weights.
The reason why lifting weights,
it's important.
I just swore off it cause I fucked up my rotator cuff.
So he's telling me there's lots of other types of weight lifting weight cause
you can do the pink ones for the one ponders I can,
I think I can handle those at this point.
300 reps.
Three reps.
Okay.
300 reps at that.
Why restrict?
There's all kinds of things.
Bands where they go on the road to take it in my hotel,
I can do everything in my hotel room.
So anyway,
I just lifting weights besides being strong.
It keeps your hormone levels up.
And when your hormone levels up,
you fighting the big three diseases,
cancer,
diabetes and heart disease.
It's proven.
So our hormone levels go down real quick before you're definitely near 20 shit
starts changing.
Testosterone levels start going down after 18 or 17 or so.
It,
it's crazy.
But anyway,
it keeps your hormone levels up,
which makes you younger to everything about it makes you youthful.
Alright,
so lifting weights does that.
It also,
the more muscle mass you build,
the more it chews on fat.
Eat your fat.
Uh,
okay,
so you know,
and I know how to carve my body.
I know that,
you know,
you do,
bench press for your chest.
You Do,
you know,
you do pull,
pull downs to get to create that v you do,
uh,
you know,
I do bench also to build your chest flied.
You flies in bench.
I know how to carve my body.
All right.
The second thing is a cardiac surgeon.
Jim,
do you have like that shit from like the eighties that old,
was it the Weeder Gi Joe Wieder things and all of that out in this old thing,
the gray on gray member,
the ground gray sweats.
I used to work in gyms like that.
Yeah,
there was old school gym with Olympians would work in those.
I called the iron pit.
Yeah.
No,
nothing pretty about it.
These are guys that want to work out,
you know.
But I had a trainer for a long time so I did that for 14 years.
So I learned how to do it right and I need to get a new one cause I'd need to
be,
you know,
get the latest techniques,
it's all about technique.
As you all know.
Rotator cuff,
you know,
people don't want,
I can help you with bad technique.
Yeah.
If you want to get hurt,
I can fucking,
I've been,
I went,
I've gone three injuries in a row and I think I'm fun.
You know,
when you,
when you bench pressed,
did you or do you,
when you did any of the ways you used to probably raise your shoulders,
right.
My shoulders were already up.
Okay.
The thing about lifting weights,
as you say,
trauma,
I was in a protective posture
too much.
I had orange hair,
heroin.
I was growing up.
I mean,
I was just God damn bull's eye by how you are both like,
yeah,
you know a fuck this white shit you might between brothers is shrink.
You go see him,
he'll help you out.
I'm done talking to those fucking fee.
I know you always gonna have problems and then they always get to sit there and
then you start doing it to other people.
Oh,
you know what that is?
That's because when you were a kid,
ice cream fell off you fucking cone and then you just become this,
this person trying to connect everything.
So I know I've just sort of accepted who I am.
I try to work on being less of,
uh,
an angry asshole is what I'm,
I'm,
I'm trying to do,
uh,
I've gotten way better.
Um,
I failed.
You're married,
right?
Yeah.
How's she dealing with it?
The angry asshole.
Nah,
she's a,
uh,
angry asshole too.
Nah,
she's a saint man.
I did.
Kids know if she ever just said,
look,
I just can't fucking deal with you anymore.
I would,
I would be hard probably back.
Get it.
I get it.
Yeah.
I get it,
you know?
But I mean,
you know,
then there's the other part of me,
it's just like,
well,
you know,
we're living nice here and I'm out here be fucking God damn every other weekend
and I suck at Madigan.
You know,
I'm out here fucking Dayton,
Ohio and when shit and Dick Jokes like,
hey,
you're watching every episode of the office.
I think I just don't get like that.
Which doesn't get you anywhere.
It feels good for a sec.
I gave up,
I gave up arguing with my wife for lent and I said,
I'm just,
I'm not going to just,
I'm not going to,
I'm finding the genius.
I used to think those guys would just like,
like they,
they just quit.
We just,
and it was those guys that's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
It's is actually,
there's the game within the game when you do that is because man,
that's heavy.
If you can do that because your emotions are raging,
you brain isn't as powerful as your emotions.
Like their thing is,
is how they get you.
Okay.
Oh well it's because they can physically beat the show.
Generally speaking,
English at Dayton,
some UFC chick,
they can't beat the fuck out.
So they have to go cerebral.
And what happens is,
is you give up all your information when you're wrong,
and when you,
I mean,
when you're mad and then they collect that.
Oh yeah.
So the thing is,
is when you don't lose your shit anymore,
all of a sudden they're there.
They're the inflammation trail that the court has been cut.
Now they don't know what the fuck you thinking.
And there's this like this,
all this shit.
I think I finally got some power back in this.
This is incredible.
So the big thing is you recognize that.
Yeah.
That's the big thing.
Because what I'm doing now,
it's like it's the execution that,
oh,
don't say that.
Don't say anything.
Yeah.
You still get smart.
You Go,
you start to learn how to be tactical like them freaks him out.
Oh Dude.
Because all of a sudden respect you though yet what they don't like.
But then what they do is then what all you did was catch up to one of this
skillset and then what happens is then,
you know,
they immediately started adjusting.
Nick,
it becomes a different that it's a tall,
it's evolving through professional at what they do and we're just learning how
to do it the better.
It's like getting the wing with Muhammad Ali.
I mean,
you might get one punch in,
then it's lights out.
Yeah.
What do you want?
My big thing is now that is my experience.
My big thing now is try this as I know there's that point where I can feel the
fucking testosterone blowing in through me and my muscles swelling and she's had
a couple glasses of wine.
She's like completely out of control and I'm perfect.
And she uh,
I just go this at one moment I just go,
she,
I shut the computer or the book or what am I'm doing?
I said,
see Ya.
And I leave.
I get,
I pull myself out of the room.
Oh,
you can walk.
I got to walk.
Because if I don't,
I've always wanted to do the walk.
I've never,
I've never been able to do.
Just say,
you know what?
I'll see it.
I'm going or just leave.
So I'm done.
That's what I say.
I'm done.
I leave because if I don't,
I got to do the clap.
The clap.
I'm done.
Seen that at least.
But that's good for both of us because what happens if,
see I'll be up all night stewing about it,
not her.
She goes to sleep,
wakes up.
Oh,
and that's why I hate honey and I'm like still raging.
I can't get past that.
I just,
I wish I could just start going in Jesus Christ.
Oh fuck.
What am I doing here?
What?
This
talk to myself.
I will.
I walked down the street one time and I didn't even give a shit who heard me?
And I know there was people looking at me.
I didn't care.
I was just like,
just practicing.
It was just like,
I will never do this again.
Yeah.
Okay.
I understand people getting married the first time,
you didn't know what you were getting into,
but people who get the second time,
it's like you,
you got three.
Oh my God,
check this.
Hey,
I'm fucking one and done.
If this shit doesn't work,
I'm not saying we're in a bad place,
but if,
if she ever just said,
fuck this,
I'm out.
I would totally get it and I would just,
I would give her everything.
Yeah.
And I would,
I would have somebody build me this,
the eye.
The drum room.
No,
the dream divorce.
See House for a guy,
which is just a garage with the fucking room above it.
Yeah.
It's a big studio.
My on an electronic drum kits.
I don't piss anybody off.
I'll have all the fucking sports packages,
little keg rate of slowly drink myself to death and a nice car.
Nice.
It's my old fucking 68 f 100 and you,
you want it every fucking thing else.
Take it.
I don't give a shit.
Well,
you know what?
I feel the same way if I don't,
if I don't,
if,
if you know,
my wife,
she's 21 years younger,
she's hot as hell.
Gina,
if she left me,
I just say,
I tell you have to worry about me cheating on you because if you leave me,
I'm done.
Oh,
never fucking live with another woman again.
And you know,
and rightfully so.
A strike three you're out.
I mean I'd be like,
no,
I'm not saying that the date and do what guys do,
but I would live alone.
You don't deserve to live with anybody.
It's,
you know,
I'll take half the blame.
I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not good enough.
I'm not equipped for this next life.
I'll do it right now.
Cause you know,
my career has always been first.
I mean,
is that when it messed up most everything always been,
it's always been,
my career has been first and we can attach that to all kinds of 40 and shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Career's always been first.
And that's what got me where I am and now I'm,
I'm,
that's what I love about my wife is she gets that because uh,
I've seen other guys deal with that where it's just like they get with somebody
and they love the lifestyle of what you do,
but then they want that nine to five guy who's going to be like,
Hey,
I'm home every night.
He the one state after a while they just get tired of that.
And then that's what fucking makes me paranoid about women is because then they
leave you,
but they take the lifestyle with them and you're the guy that earned it and now
you have to continue going out doing what the fuck it is you do while you give
all the lifestyle money to them and then they meet this other fucking nine to
five asshole and they get to live this rockstar shit and,
and you know,
cake and eat it.
Yeah.
Kate Gideon.
That's the reality.
That's,
that's a definite,
that is a definite reality is that you bring that up.
It's considered like a misogynistic and all that type of shit though too,
which is,
that's the thing,
that's that all of this me too shit that's going on right now where they're,
they're examining the male female dynamic,
which obviously needs to be done.
It's obviously a good thing to,
to,
I mean,
I,
I had no idea all this fucking shit was going on,
so that's all good.
But what I love about this,
it's like we're gonna examine the male female dynamic,
but it's,
it's only going to critique what guys do when the relationship.
So at that point you kind of suggested that women are like,
these completed works and meanwhile they're fucking killing us.
Every guy dies before their wife.
They always outlive us.
They blame us.
Say,
you know,
go to the fucking doctor.
You know,
I'm going to the doctor,
I'm going,
I'm getting everything fucking checked out.
I'm going to just,
just to fucking prove them wrong.
My wife is still going to kill me.
I swear to God she has.
I have all my shots.
I tell everyone I'm going to live long and all you fuckers,
I got that old man,
she's got to do that.
I'm going to fucking live.
I'm just,
I'll be hanging on stubbornness.
Hang on.
You know.
Hey you,
you know,
I'll be paralyzed on one side.
I mean,
you can tell me communicate and three a little bell like that dude and breaking
bad.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
It's pretty crazy.
I mean,
you know,
it's just typical of anything like this.
It swings way over to the other side and it,
and there's definitely some,
definitely some issues and things to be addressed.
I mean,
without mentioning names,
bad behavior is bad behavior.
I agree.
Bad behavior is bad behavior,
but this,
it's gets to the point where then you've got so many gray areas and so many
things to consider that aren't just what's going on in the news,
that it's not just,
there's something else going on in,
in,
and they're trying to like just put it all into one little cubicle.
I'm gonna get my ass kicked for this.
But you know,
it's not a one year to get in trouble here.
I don't want you,
I don't want you to go,
no,
you're not.
You're not getting me in trouble.
What
do you think,
uh,
music today?
What are some of the bands like everyone's always tracking on my God,
what happened to and blah,
blah,
blah.
[inaudible] what do you,
what do you,
are you liking music this day?
Is,
does take this,
I take mediocrities in.
And what do you do you think part of that was because all,
all the studios they used to have like the fucking guy you wanted to produce
your record and now it's like,
it's just fucking people at home.
No,
it's real simple.
Well,
you're right.
But the reason,
the reason behind all the change or one of the big reasons behind the change,
uh,
is that,
you don't buy cds.
There's no income coming in.
I'm on three cds that sold 40 million a piece to Celine Dion records in a
meatloaf bad on a hill too.
He's sold over 40 million,
not including downloads.
Think about now,
if the artist is making 18 cents on the dollar,
that's 82 cents.
The labeled times 40 Mil,
that's going to pay some bills.
The business model was it allows with Mellencamp.
They,
if you could spend,
we could spend a year making a record,
you know,
cause we were doing an Indiana,
which is cheaper,
but actually we did it and other places,
but we could spend a year working on a record.
If we made a record and music suck,
you throw it away and start again.
And also,
by the way,
back then,
if you didn't have a good course,
a good hook line to a unique sound,
unique,
this unique,
that unique that you wouldn't even get played on the radio because everybody
else was doing that.
You will competing against the greatest records that have come out in a long
time.
Right?
And so,
but there was money.
That's my point.
And when the record came out,
it was $1 million.
You could invest if they want it to $1 million to get that record played on the
radio cost,
the United States.
Not to mention the marketing plan for the Europe and in Asia and England and
Australia.
Then when you went on tour,
there was tour support.
There was money to invest in a band to build a career and the way it is,
nothing more powerful than a bunch of guys working together.
Let's see.
Beatles stones,
you to,
you know,
um,
the who of these bands?
It's the hope led Zeppelin.
I mean,
these bands work together.
Didn't even matter if they got along.
The point is all the talent in one room created this incredible team that
created incredible epic product.
One guy can't do what for guys.
That's like Michael Jordan was the most dangerous basketball player in the
world.
Why?
He figured it out.
It wasn't about him.
It was about the team and that's what scared the other people.
Yeah.
That's not a coach of the piston saying that one year when Mike showed up,
the first game they played them,
they collapsed the d on Him and he passed the ball and he went,
oh shit.
Of course he's still dominated and took over the game.
But once he started doing that,
he added that whole dynamic to his game and it was over.
The point is you look at him,
you know he's going to do the right thing for the team.
That's scary man.
Because I mean he's,
he's a coach and a player.
So I mean the teams are greater than individual.
One guy thinks that he can do as much as five.
That's crazy.
But because of the budgets,
we've been forced into those cubicles,
we've been forced to.
People have to,
there is no budget.
I have a studio right up the road there and people come over and they,
and they,
they,
they want me to record drums,
have an engineer.
I was a control room in a dorm moon and I've done like Sammy Hagar,
Billy Gibbons,
Steve Lucas or all kinds of,
but most of the work I get is people sending me files from all over the world
when they save up their little money and they have,
you know,
44 decades of experience and my style,
literally write a song and be like,
I want to get Kenny Aaron.
Oh yeah,
I send you a little bit of Zip,
whatever the fuck they called,
zip five of them.
RECIPROC,
reciprocator,
whatever the fuck they call,
they send you that.
I load it into my pro tools.
So I asked this,
I asked for the click they used on the session because man,
the times I haven't gotten a click,
it's a disaster.
If they didn't play to a click track.
Oh for fuck.
And it takes me longer.
So because of the budget I want,
I would love to see you and your drum room.
Jesus fucking Christ,
you slow it down again.
Something like that.
Wow.
I get to click,
I want the click.
They used the session,
I put that into pro tools on one track and I can control the volume.
Then I sell him to send me the demo with the drum sequences,
stuff that they use because nine out of 10 times,
that's what they're in love with.
Then send me the song without the drums because that's what I'm going to play
do.
I'm gonna play the song without the drum sequence and the click.
Do you do you before?
Uh,
you know,
you play what they already put down.
Oh yeah.
Do you play what you would play?
They don't have their shit in your head.
No.
I play,
first I do is I play exactly what they program.
Then I started making adjustments like instead of open high and I might go to
the crash cymbal or go to the ride cymbal or the first take,
I give them three tanks.
First take is pretty much what they had,
but it's with my feel.
And then I started doing more fills that are me.
Uh,
I do different things and I'm thinking they could pick from this.
And the third take I go even further.
And that's,
that's,
that's my really,
my definition of creativity is to start with the foundation and then build off
of that.
And,
um,
sometimes I'll give four takes if I think you know what.
And um,
and then I send it back to them and they typically go for take two,
three is I've gone too far or they might grab like he was doing the song for
Sammy Hagar and I said,
you know,
I really think the song,
he just sent me a guitar and vocal and a click,
he can still sing.
It sounds ridiculous and just easy.
Just put it here in ridiculous.
He said one of them,
let me know next time you guys are playing.
Oh Dude.
This was like,
I was playing with him,
the guys from Stone Temple pilots,
uh,
some guys from the cult,
some guys Foma,
Matt Sorum and I were playing together.
Steve Stevens,
I mean somebody from the stones.
It was great.
It was a music thing to get kids,
uh,
you know,
instruments in schools.
But I thought you were describing when all you guys are doing it was a music
thing.
Oh yeah.
I didn't think you guys are playing basketball
too.
I had to clarify that.
Yeah.
So anyways,
so I got it.
That was really interesting.
So they usually end up taking like take two,
which makes sense because they're not dramas and then you,
you,
but they know what they want.
And then you should see,
I gotta show you what my,
what my charts and those anal chart writer in the planet.
Uh,
this is his cause.
I'm,
hey,
why you look for that?
And I want to ask a question then I drum for the longest fucking time.
I've always wanted to ask a drama with your setup.
I don't know if you still do this.
Do you versed?
Yeah.
Why do you,
for people at home listening,
he would have like what have you,
12,
12 inch to 10 inch,
10 inch going and you are right handed drummer going left to right.
Wow.
Minutes takes me to it and then they'll read it and make it sound like I'm not
reading.
Make it feel like I'm not reading.
That's you're looking at as Trump shot.
Oh,
that is so fucking cool.
It's like Chinese.
Yeah.
So,
so how do you usually,
for people who don't play drums listening to this,
you go,
hello.
Low Height alone.
So you eight 10 12 1416 going down and you go like 21016181618
what happened was I got Mellencamp band and I,
I,
when I auditioned I showed up with a car with leaky oil and I had this big ass,
you know Neil Peart from rush to I'm set.
John looks at me,
looks at the car,
it looks at the drums,
shakes my hand.
John Mellencamp turns around and walks the other direction like,
wow,
he will not happy.
I didn't look cool.
The car's leaking on his driveway and I got a drum set that's like not cool.
He says,
this guy's not going work out.
I crushed it though.
I just beat the shit,
broke everything.
He was this close to me.
His mouth was open like Holy Shit,
who?
This guy is into it.
Anyway,
I get in the band but immediately said,
ah,
another time when someone is just looking at you like,
no,
and you just,
yeah,
go,
went over the top.
Well if you did that book,
you'll see where he cut me from the first record five weeks later and you told
him to go home.
I said,
no,
I ain't going home.
I'm not fucking going home.
It's no way I was going to be mortified.
I'd rather go to Mars.
There's no way we're going because I didn't have enough.
I didn't know how to serve a song.
You know what?
I'd tell a drummer and we'll get back to the tenants.
Dom.
I say,
do you know what the purpose of a drone was when you're making a record?
Nobody ever gets it.
They're going to get it now cause I've said it enough,
but the go beat time.
I says,
no,
get the fucking song on the radio to be number one.
That's your job because when you do that,
you just made the company millions of dollars.
You just made the record label or you made the artist or the band millions of
dollars.
If Microsoft hired us,
they don't give a fuck about us.
They just want us to make money and they smile.
And when we make money for them,
they give us some money.
We take care of our family.
It's that simple.
And then nobody ever tells you that shit.
But that's why I didn't get on the first record.
I played with Leonard Bernstein.
I was at Tanglewood,
I got the juice and symphony orchestra.
What the fuck does that have to do with getting a song on the radio to be number
one?
I didn't know.
I was looking through a telescope and that is looking through a microscope where
you so different direction,
isn't it?
And I didn't understand that.
And I eventually did obviously,
but I,
when I'm a fighter fight guy,
I didn't know that.
So I wrote this book.
I thought it was just this nice,
I can't wait to read this.
I can't wait to go left.
So John said he'd like Charlie was,
he wanted the Charlie watts one rack.
Tom One floor tone,
one ride cymbal when crashing a Hyatt.
That's it.
So that was really tough cause you know drummers are really particular about
their setups.
I went,
all right,
that's really pissed about that.
But okay.
I did it.
And um,
and then we went on tour.
Uh,
let's see,
maybe I did the first tour with one retcon but then Jack and Diane,
which was the next record,
which I vowed I'd be on the next record,
which I was,
because it has that big drum solo boom,
black students do better with Jews.
Did you do to do to do better to boob and it was four times so iconic to hear
you sing.
So I'm playing or maybe this is what happened before Jack.
And then I had a 12 inch direct come,
a 16 inch floor,
Tom and an 18 didn't even have hardware on the bottom.
I just didn't have,
I didn't even have a deal yet,
didn't even hardware.
And I had the Evan's hydraulic heads.
You remember those fat,
the kids didn't have the oil in the middle of the,
and this was like,
and so the engineer comes up to me and we're playing,
woven up to 18 is like a concert time.
Like there's no bottom head.
No problem.
Hey Buddy,
we're opening up for the kinks.
So we planned a big venues and the engineer comes up to me,
he goes,
Kenny,
you Thomas,
I can't get enough definition out of those drums.
Um,
do you kind of smaller Tom.
And I went,
well I do,
but John doesn't want it.
And this is when I had this direct come on,
a snare stand.
I didn't mount it,
I didn't want it was old school.
So,
uh,
I said,
well,
I got a smaller town but John's not going to like it.
And then I went,
hey,
tell John his vocal will sound way better if I have that 10 inch time up there.
I was just joking and I dunno if he told them that,
but the bottom line is he says,
put the other Tom up.
So,
but I didn't have a hold of foresight to put on a snare stands.
So I've got a 24 inch.
She kicked her on Mondays.
Tom's or like you could drive a freight train through it,
but why?
Why wouldn't you just put the 10?
Because at this point I realized the value and the perfection of snare 1216 is
the sound like a jazz drummer and now you go back to they weren't dummies.
They were all into like not what looks good,
but what sounds good.
Putting a 10 inch right there with a 12 inch.
I wasn't gonna go for it.
I wouldn't know how you go 10 I guess I could have put the high hat outs farther
and then squeezed the 10 inch even far left and leave the 12 word is,
but I decided to reverse it.
Yeah,
probably avoided hip problems too.
Cause then you like just being just another two inches after 40 years all of a
sudden as fuck.
Well yeah.
So yeah,
that became my thing.
And then think about if you put your hand out 10 then lefthand 12 right hand 16
dude does that.
But I'm sure that some of the fields I did was so out there.
Some guy in Japan was trying to try to analyze the shit gone.
How do you do that?
You right.
You try to figure out the sticking.
Yeah.
I hate that.
I hate when that happens.
Then you'll have like,
like all the,
you know,
the whole,
the bottom,
the kick right left and they went kick left,
right.
Everybody in England would kick left.
Right.
So it had that descending sound that way.
I do it like Barnum.
I'd go left hand on the Rackham went to go get,
get to get the together.
I go left hand,
right hand,
left foot.
That's what bonded.
And you know that,
that,
that fill that he does in a um,
uh,
black black dog goes,
that's cause he leads with his left hand so he can go left to the rack.
Tom Left,
which is debt to get to that [inaudible] that snare Tom Snare foot,
but then he can move his snare foot.
Yeah,
I think it's like no fucking
snare.
Snare Tom.
So
he doesn't like that because he's so talented.
He just thought,
well why crossover my hands and why he just made his hands do what?
Execute a thing to get the sound he wanted.
So want to go duck,
duck,
go to God.
So he do lefthanded that good dude that as opposed to most people go to the drug
so they don't want to,
that's one of the leading with the right hand,
the right hand and second of all it's easier.
So,
but not bottom.
No,
no.
He says duck.
Duck.
Why did you ever see those guys live far?
I saw lots of first time you haven't been sitting up straight.
You just [inaudible] I know.
I saw a dude,
that guy,
I mean to me
do you have it's like death Royal Albert Hall that just the way that that
concert looks.
So you don't have that DVD that released about 15 years ago.
Um,
and his drum sound,
it's just,
I,
you know what's funny about that guy,
I was talking to a song about this,
there's like this whole like,
I think it's a myth that he played like these to be giant tree trunk stick.
It'd be looking at is things like he's playing like a five.
May I ask you something?
Do you remember what heads he's using in that?
That,
that,
is that how the West was won?
That thing that does,
that all came up back then.
Okay.
Do you know what to him has he had on the Royal Albert Hall any of that time?
Well,
he,
you still have the black dot.
Like Tony.
Okay.
That's what he did have.
That southern remains the same he had though
on the,
well and the how the West is one coated ambassador.
Not only did he have coated ambassador,
he had on his,
kicked him too dude.
I'd blow through that shit and like three songs,
coating ambassador and he had um oh and the snare drum.
You remember when you were a little kid,
you play snare to them and get,
you don't change the head cause you don't play that hard.
You had to stare at them and it turns black and then the inside of that black
gets beat out.
Clear and you could see through the,
that means you,
that drum heads been on there for 80 years.
He had snared them live with that look on that.
Started studying his muscles and his,
the way he wasn't hitting that hard hit an incredible foot.
But he wasn't hitting that hard because you cannot play a coated ambassador
heads and and make it and have it last in a live show like they were doing.
He couldn't hit him that hard.
It's hair was flying around.
It looked like he was just a beast and he's big,
but I wasn't his muscles and his everyday way he moves.
It's all wrists and fingers.
I played for my belly button.
I'm like martial arts player started off with mallets when Stub Marimba you had
to lift with your risk because to get the yarn off of the wooden bar.
So I developed this technique,
Timpani,
I use fingers to get the stick to just bounce off the Timpani,
use your fingers and then we're still going to do both because when you do
double stroke low,
you go wrist down and then fingers to get the rebound.
And then when I started playing rock and roll,
I started to use that wrist thing and I started to go into my forearm,
then into my upper arm and then I started going with my back and I start to
realize,
well shit,
I'm going to do the Bruce Lee thing.
Start playing from my gut.
And you know,
that's how just what little I know obviously I just think he just knew Bonham
just knew how to hit a drum.
You know how to hit it and get the fuck out of the way of it and let it.
Yup.
Cause I remember what my generation coming up in the 80s all like all his
teenager.
We would,
that's,
that was the thing when people just,
you know,
you'd hit the bass drum and leave the beat on it and you try to like just,
just bash because his sound was so big.
It was also too,
I mean there was production value to it and everything.
So we were sitting there trying to find a 26 inch base to him,
you know,
trying to get that sound.
Yeah.
You had to hit hard.
And number of buying these big stupid like the marching band,
Styx thinking and had just sounded like absolute shit.
I would just sound like I was hitting a wet piece of notebook paper when I would
hit it and it just would never work.
But
it was it.
That's the whole point of this thing is that,
look,
what you hear is,
isn't what you doesn't add up to what you actually do to get that sound.
There's so many variables.
Let me ask you a few more before,
before we
gotta wrap this up,
because I could literally talk to you about who's a most underrated drummer.
Oh,
there's a lot of underrated drummer.
Phil Rudd for ACDC.
Unbelievable.
It's what?
More like what?
He doesn't do a,
okay.
I just saw,
I just did music cares in New York where don was a musical director.
Producer hires me to do these big,
huge things while play with 20 artists,
all kinds of styles.
Meryl Haggard recently,
Greg Home and doctor John Fleetwood Mac.
That's my whole point for MusiCares and I watched Fleetwood Mac Rehearse at the,
we've done rehearsing.
I played with eight artists.
I want to watch them.
Then Mick Fleetwood fucker,
he was another guy.
He switched the Tom's right?
Yeah.
And then he had like,
he had to have that,
the extension on his high heck,
cause he was like ninth,
just like nine feet tall.
But the thing is is that
these drummers were guys,
I became the drummer I used to make fun of when I was in college.
Like fuck that Nigel also shit,
this Guy Charlie Watts,
you know,
even Ringo who I thought it was my idol.
He is.
My idol was,
but then I went on like,
you know me,
Billy come pretty much fucked up my career because I was trying to
play like him.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
that's a young guy.
That's a young person's thought.
Like if I gotta go,
I gotta go play as many notes as I can and showing off and doing all that.
I knocked,
obviously not trash.
And Billy Conn told Billy comments as humans fucked up my career in my book.
I said,
but you know,
and we're friends.
I,
there's no way I was ever going to be like Billy come and I learned a lot by
trying.
My point is,
is that,
um,
I had to learn to appreciate how brilliant a guy like Charlie watts who were
windows stars and Phil Rudd and uh,
Oh,
there's a whole slew of them.
My favorite thing about Phil Rudd is when they're coming out of like the versus
or something like that,
it's just always that point.
You,
you think that he's going to hit the crash and he goes,
I know was playing.
And then when he finally does,
he's just built up so much tension and then the song just like,
it just fucking takes off.
It took me,
I used to,
I used to.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean obviously I became a comedian so I made a lot of,
well you didn't make that mistake.
Uh,
no,
but I didn't learn.
I didn't learn that until,
uh,
you know,
I was probably a comedian for 15 years.
You know,
there's that initial thing we played ACDC cause you think it's easy and you
think you're playing it but you're not playing the physically you're doing it.
And it took the longest times until I saw guys like Steve Jordan and even Steve
Gadd one time would just play the most simple beat and I just would watch those
guys.
An example right there being like I can physically play that,
but I could never even remotely make it sound.
It all comes from your head first.
You got to hear it.
Yeah.
Somebody saw me doing,
I did another music cares.
I was a honor and Dylan here in La,
some drummers I decided in between the rehearsal and the filming and recording,
it just shows by the way,
16 cameras shoot,
they're going to record it.
You can't fuck up.
And you just finished her harassing with three artists and how you got,
that's why I write everything out,
you know?
So anyway,
this guy,
I decided,
I talked to the engineer and said,
I just feel like in this room my symbols with Blake,
I'm going to put up some case symbols.
Do you me?
So I'm playing the simple glue,
just laying it down,
being doing what I do in some drummer for this other band is looking at me,
shaking his head.
Then he comes over and I said,
it's something wrong with the symbols.
He goes,
no,
how the fuck do you make those drum sound like that?
How do you get that sound?
You're not doing any fancy.
So he was telling me what I'm in awe of other drums like,
oh,
you know,
and I said,
how do I do that?
Says Cause I hear something,
I imagined something in my head,
maybe it's John Bonham and I imagined something in my heart.
I'm just chasing after it,
chasing after every hit,
everything I'm always going.
Does that sound like I want it to sound and feel the way I want the feel.
So it doesn't matter what notes I'm playing him.
Cheat on directing myself,
making adjustments with my right hand,
my left hand,
my right foot,
my left foot,
everything,
my posture,
everything to get that kind of sound.
Am I getting that sound that I'm feeling and imagine it.
So I haven't been just doing just doing it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it was a pet peeve of mine and still is to this day when you're watching a music
video,
but you don't see a lot of them the amount of fucking times where they never had
the drummer sinked incorrectly.
He said the snare and he's always hitting a kick and vice versa,
and it's just the fucking worse.
Or you hear him playing the high hat and he's fucking crashed and assemble date
this,
they never have any fucking respect for a drummer.
And I gotta tell you something,
dude,
the amount of respect I I already had for you.
And just listen to them,
you know,
the whole background and how all this stuff you've overcome in your whole
attitude towards it is that you're an inspirational guy.
And,
uh,
and,
and you sang the Jack and Diane Filomeno.
I'm fucking completed it.
This,
this is fantastic.
And he's got a new book out called sex,
drugs and rock and roll.
Uh,
Kenny Aronoff,
thank you so much for coming on the podcast that I should say that,
you know,
you say speaking inspirational.
I've been doing a lot of,
uh,
his article in Forbes.
I sent you that.
Uh,
I don't know if he got it.
I said,
have a look at emails.
I'll look for it.
Not Email.
Is this text you put it,
but the point is up.
Didn't do a lot of speaking.
That book gave me the inspiration to go out and I have a whole show.
I'm going to do marathon oil in two days.
Well,
I have a whole hour and 15 minute show was as Christ.
I'm going to be opening for you,
so let me know.
Anyway,
let me do 20 minutes.
Katie,
I can't believe I forgot who I was.
I was joking and telling you I have the VHS copies that I bought like the,
I don't know how many I bought them in the 90s where it was like a,
you'll be a power house until I fucking,
I gotta we gotta hang it some fun cause I got to,
I want to do this.
I never do autographs.
I just want to,
I know things.
I do.
Thank you so much.
Awesome.
All right guys.
Thank you for listening.